where's taylor at now throw your hair
out where's taylor at now oh is that
taylor yeah oh is that you yeah oh okay
okay let's you know then you get the
pass i was gonna say is taylor around
right now well she's in the same room so
you're not
is that corny that he got your name
tattooed on him
i was [ __ ] like 22 though so you guys
are like
you're like 34. i'm like 24. i was 24.
first of all i'm a grown-ass man i knew
what i was doing okay girl that's bad
decisions second of all
you're gonna go by yukon you and i are
both
you and i are both the same we each have
a tattoo of the girl we're still with
right you got married like you didn't
have to do that like she's just waiting
for you to marry her this was like this
is the whole dog she just said she's
waiting she said you're right this gave
me like three years that you didn't have
all right so since we're doing this
when it's like like what
so so you did this as like a uh here
this is like a
this will buy me three more years until
i have to wait but i ain't ready to jump
off the porch
so
that was eight years ago
this was like four years ago okay but
you've known your girl for how long
i kissed six tomorrow
so
like seven eight
hmm so when you're gonna when you're
gonna pop the question man i'm just
putting you on the spot i'm 30 and i
wasn't getting married before i turned
30. i'm not so now you're technically in
marriage territory because now you're
30. got an album i got like another
album
that's a wild knowing you you're not
gonna get married till he's [ __ ] 40.
he said yeah after the next album which
is gonna be in 2029
this is guys the [ __ ] chattanooga dr
dre making his weight like it's a
[ __ ] detox every four years jesus
well taylor turned to tables shout out
to taylor she's here your lovely your
lovely wife she's wife by proxy you know
eight years that's wife she's your wife
i guess i was i always hit you with i
will let you go that's all good listen
it's cool
hey listen we're both in amazing
relationships and we both have our
amazing women's name tattooed on our
body